from both our governments we would do  everything in all circumstances to clear  up all the debris of the airplane take  it from the crash site of course this is  extremely difficult and extremely  difficult times for all the family  members and of course amongst all of  this our thoughts are still deeply with  you yesterday during my visit at the  crash site I have promised to everybody  to our family to our friends to  compatriots to everybody who may have  lost somebody in this catastrophe we  will of course do everything to support  the further investigations because of  course we owe this to all the people who  have lost their lives in the terrible  crash earlier on this week I